and now to talk about scientific
revolutions is industrial artist matthew
dockery take it away
hey
so in 1665 the world's oldest scientific
journal philosophical transactions
started publication
and for the last year i've been working
on a project where i read them starting
with issue number one
i dig up all the historical context i
can for the articles put it together
make a video about it and post it
it's been a lot of work but also a lot
of fun and
i've learned some stuff that i thought i
would share with you here
so it was a project of the royal society
of london one of their first big
projects actually
and their secretary henry oldenburg
had long been the center of a kind of
scientific pen pal network spanning
europe
and the journal was really a
formalization of that
it saved him the effort of handwriting
out all the copies i suppose
he mostly saw it as a way to make money
on the side but well unfortunately for
him that never worked very well
but it worked pretty well for everyone
else but to really understand
philosophical transactions you have to
go back even further in this earlier in
the century to francis bacon he was a
mildly corrupt court official who was
absolutely convinced that
academics had been doing everything
wrong for centuries
if you wanted to learn about the world
you had to do experiments you couldn't
just sit around and think about it
really hard
in his book the new organon he very
explicitly says that we need to move
away from deductive reasoning and
embrace inductive reasoning instead
the uh the old satire about angels on
the head of a pen well he didn't write
it but it was from his time and he
probably would have approved he even
wrote a story called the new atlantis
about a fictional island kingdom at the
center of which is solomon's house
which to a modernize can only really be
described as a research institute they
gather knowledge about the world study
it and use it as the basis for further
experiments
and by following this technique the
fictional kingdom has gained some really
amazing technological powers including
well what we would call televisions and
submarines and recorded music it's an
oddly prophetic book in a lot of ways
but this was still a very
centralized very top-down understanding
of science
bacon thought that the project should be
first to collect all the facts about the
world natural histories on fire and air
and birds and everything and once you've
done that it would probably only be the
project of a couple years for people to
go through and look at it all and figure
out the rules and how the world works
well this was convincing enough that
several decades later some people were
really trying to make it happen
the royal society grew out of a series
of public lectures at gresham college
some public lectures not too unlike
these actually
and they were very explicitly trying to
start
solomon's house and a big part of that
would be tools of communication which is
where the journal came in
now the first couple decades were pretty
rough they started just in time for the
plague
and then they got back from that just in
time for the great fire and then
oldenburg was thrown into the tower
under suspicion of being a dutch spy
but it was also rough because they
didn't know what they were doing and
that's really the joy out of reading the
early issues is that you get to see them
inventing the very concept of scientific
publication from issue to issue
the contents were also rough and kind of
a mixed bag
you get the earliest recorded
record of the great red spot of jupiter
and it's next to a description of a
deformed head of a monstrous calf there
are book reviews and trip reports and a
lot of descriptions of mining technology
but for me one of the other big joys is
getting to see how different
the actual process of the scientific
revolution was compared to the stories
we tell about it today
so take astronomy as an example there
are a lot of articles about cometary
motion and many of them end with a note
to the effect that maybe this will help
settle the grand question of the earth's
motion
now remember we are 120 years after
copernicus at this point and 30 years
after galileo those kind of paradigm
shifts really have a much longer tail
than history books usually indicate to
us
when we're learning science it's a very
sanitized version with all the dead ends
removed and presenting a nice linear
narrative
but real science is messy and petty and
weird and it always has been
now the glory of science is that it
works even despite that but they didn't
know that at the time they really
thought they were forming
uh solomon's house and would just sort
of dispassionately argue about the facts
and do experiments and instead they got
confusion and infighting and a distinct
lack of decorum
but they still generated the greatest
engine for the development of knowledge
the world had ever seen it wasn't what
they intended but it worked
and the communication of scientific
results to the journal was a really
integral part of that by scaling up
oldenburg's pen pal network they turned
it into something completely different
it had made the private public and it
let science be more than just a hobby
for rich weirdos
um and that's at least something i'm
very thankful for
so basically the scientific method works
despite who's
doing it
exactly
um and we're just kind of lucky that
they let it keep going even though it
really failed to live up to so many of
their ideals beforehand
which is your uh
favorite story from back then
oh um
there was this amazing exchange between
robert hook
and this french astronomer adrian nazoo
and hook had just published his
magnificent book micrographia which is
just filled with these amazing
illustrations the flea in these slides
is from that it's a pretty famous image
but as also part of the book like he got
a chance to write a book so he was going
to put in everything he could and one of
the things he shoved in there was this
idea he had for how to improve lens
grinding there's a whole new mechanism
for doing it but he'd never actually
tried it he just like here's what i
think would work and azure writes into
the journal saying this really doesn't
live up to our grand baconian ideals of
basing everything on personal experience
and experimentation
and hook just loses it at that uh with
some amazing vitriolic attacks and
response including an amazing argument
that the zoo was really the hypocrite
because azu hadn't done an experiment to
prove the device wouldn't work
um and to me that just really summarizes
just how quickly things got pretty nasty
actually and that's not even course
getting into the more famous disputes
between uh newton and others later in
the century
if someone wanted to read like a book on
this topic what would you recommend
oh that is a very good question um
i don't remember the name of it off the
top of my head i'm sorry um there's one
i'm thinking of
uh
and it's sitting behind me somewhere
well
we'll follow up later and share it in
the show notes i will do thank you very
much matthew thank you